alors je vais demander à nos amis
secrétaires nationaux de libérer la
place et la relève va monter j'appelle
Christian Saint-Étienne angélique de lae
Marie-Christine dalallose maot de
fonenois une question pendant qu'on fait
la
rotation monsieur le Président chers
amis l'agriculture
l'agroalimentaire les activités agricole
et rural représentent 80 % sont
présentes sur 80 % du territoire
national et vous savez les agriculteurs
actuellement sont déboussolés il y a une
crise grave conjoncturelle et structurel
alors il y a deux grands sujets qui
concernent l'agriculture c'est la
politique agricole commune et toutes les
dimensions
environnementales la politique agricole
commune c'est une grande réussite de
l'Europe et il faut une agriculture
européenne il faut une politique
agricole commune mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à 28 on a le sentiment
qu'elle est un peu moins commune qu'à sa
création alors que pouvons-nous faire
proposer quelle mesures fores en matière
de politique agricole commune pour avoir
à nouveau une forte politique agricole
commune dans notre Europe et en matière
environnementale il y a des normes
intéressantes qui permettent d'aller
vers ou de faire progresser une
agriculture durable et puis il y a des
normes qui sont punitives et comment
peut-on régler cette question merci
merci Stéphane secrétaire départemental
du Loiret nous avons la spécialiste pour
te répondre angélique de la Merci
bonjour d'abord à toutes et à tous
bonjour Stéphane c'est effectivement une
question majeure que l'avenir de la
politique agricole commune cette
politique que nous connaissons a été
rafistolée depuis un certain nombre
d'années elle a aujourd'hui 30 ans je
pense qu'il est plus que temps de
reposer les bases d'une nouvelle
politique agricole commune mais pour ça
il faut une France forte or force de
constater aujourd'hui que là où vous
m'avez élu en tant que député européen
siégant avec Michel dtin en commission
agriculture et avec Françoise grostet en
commission Environnement la France ne
rayonne plus et il faut repenser une
nouvelle politique agricole commune et
pour ça il faut inventer de nouveaux
outils la politique agricole commune a
été démantelée de tous ces outils de
régulation depuis maintenant un certain
nombre d'années sous la houlette d'une
vision très libérale alors à cet endroit
je dirais que le départ de nos amis
anglais n'est pour la politique agricole
commune pas forcément une très mauvaise
nouvelle plutôt même une nouvelle
intéressante qui nous permettra d'avoir
une vision plus structuré en tous les
cas sans exception anglaise permanente
et aujourd'hui je me suis attelé je me
suis attelé à Ha travail de la de la
création d'outils sur la volatilité des
prix puisque c'est le ciment d'une
nouvelle politique agricole commune et
les républicains au travers du groupe
PPE sont aujourd'hui en travaux de
réflexion sur des propositions pour la
nouvelle politique agricole commune je
pourrais dire encore beaucoup de choses
mais je crois que nous sommes déjà fort
en retard et donc je rends la parole
merci stéan pour cette question et je
sais que les militants peuvent compter
sur moi pour travailler d'arrache-pied à
cette nouvelle politique merci angélique
juste un mot si vous avez à quitté la
salle vous le faites mais vous le faites
en silence pour que ceux qui sont dans
la salle puissent écouter les orateurs
j'appelle Jean-François
Copé mes chers amis permettez-moi de
vous dire à mon tour combien je suis
très heureux de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour ce conseil national
parce que c'est vrai que
les conseils nationaux ce sont
évidemment des réunions de travail de
débat c'est aussi des moments pour se
retrouver je voudrais remercier Nicolas
d'avoir pris cette initiative ce conseil
national il est important à moins d'un
an de l'élection présidentielle et à
quelques mois de de la primaire une
primaire qui a pas commencé bien sûr
mais c'est vrai que déjà les débats à
droite battent son plein et tant mieux
parce que nous avons un moment
privilégié pour se dire choses vous
savez comme beaucoup parmi vous je
tourne évidemment sans relâche en France
et je reviens confortter dans mes
convictions par la réaction des très
nombreux militants mais aussi des
Français que nous sommes les uns et les
autres amenés à côtoyer à rencontrer
vous savez si je devais le résumer d'une
phrase et c'est ça que je veux partager
avec vous ce matin cela pourrait se
résumer de la manière suivante les
français où qu'ils se trouvent quel que
soit leur sensibilité d'ailleurs ne se
sentent plus
commandé jamais sans doute notre pays
n'a connu une telle crise du
commandement c'est-à-dire du processus
du de décision publique et cet
effondrement du processus de décision
politique en réalité il est sans doute
ce qui restera comme l'élément le plus
désastreux du bilan de François Hollande
quel que soit ce qu'on peut penser de
ces options évidemment nous les
combattons ici ce qui reste le plus
clair c'est qu'il n'y a plus aujourd'hui
de chef de l'État en situation de
prendre les décisions essentielles pour
l'avenir de la
France mais c'est vrai il nous
interpelle aussi et ils nous disent à
chaque fois la même chose pourquoi vous
reculez pourquoi est-ce que vous voulez
séduire une gauche qui de toute façon ne
votera jamais pour vous d'où cette idée
pour laquelle je me bats
unlassablement que j'ai appelé la droite
décomplexée vous savez ce qu'il y a
derrière cette idée est assez simple
c'est de comprendre avant même de savoir
ce que nous allons proposer pourquoi
depuis des années lorsque nous voulons
initier des réformes le pays se bloque
et je crois donc que l'un des éléments
clés qui doit nous engager avec les
Français c'est un changement radical de
méthode la gravité de la situation fait
que les Français sont prêts à entendre
que nous devons utiliser une méthode
comparable à celle qui a utilisé en son
temps général de Gaulle en 1958 quand
tout allait si mal comme maintenant il a
décidé alors que tout s'effondrait
rappelez-vous c'était un moment où il y
avait des dizaines de milliers de jeunes
Français qui étaient sous les drapeau
avec les guerres d'Indochine et
d'Algérie qu'il y avait des gouvernement
qui durait 4 mois des déficites abisau
cons se tiraé à balréel dans les rues de
Paris à ce moment-là il est arrivé avec
un paquet d'ordonnances de décisions qui
étaient prêtes et par la procédure
prévue par la Constitution en 2 mois il
a réussi à remettre le pays en ordre de
marche pour les 15 années qui ont
suivi cette politique par ordonnance est
à mes yeux la seule manière de s'en
sortir peut-être souvenez-vous de ce
qu'aveit dit en d'autre temps margarette
tcher interrogé sur les raisons qui
avaient permis qu'elle remette la
Grande-Bretagne en ordre de marche elle
avait dit vous savez j'ai gouverneré la
Grande-Bretagne pendant 10 ans la
première année j'ai tout décidé les
années suivantes ont été é dédié à
appliquer à mettre en œuvre à évaluer à
faire en sorte qu'on perde moins de
temps à savoir si on décide ou pas et
plus de temps à mobiliser l'ensemble du
pays pour le destin et pour l'avenir de
nos enfants c'est ça c'est ça que je
veux vous proposer il y a beaucoup de
leçons à tirer du fiasco de la loi
elcomery beaucoup beaucoup en vérité la
primaire ce sera évidemment l'occasion
sans doute de grand débat et pour les
électeurs de choisir entre une droite
décomplexée ou une droite peut-être plus
tiède mais ce sera aussi l'occasion de
savoir quel mode de gouvernement on veut
et quel mode de gouvernement voudront
les Français il y a deux choix possibles
soit on continue la cogestion avec des
syndicats minoritaires extrémistes
violents qui en réalité impose leur
dictature ou bien on rétablit l'autorité
politique en réalité le seul qui a la
légitimité pour décider c'est le
président de la République qu'il qu'il
consulte qu' dialogue sans doute mais
c'est lui qui a la légitimité parce que
c'est lui qui a été élu au suffrage
universel et il est soutenu par sa
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
ainsi que fonctionnent toutes les
grandes démocraties mes chers amis et je
voudrais appeler votre attention
là-dessus il n'a jamais été écrit nulle
part que les démocraties devaient être
faibles or ce que nous voyons avec la
loi comery c'est une démocratie qui
s'effondre sur elle-même parce que le
moindre minoritaire violent agressif
menaçant l'emporte sur la l du suffrage
universel c'est cela mes chers amis
qu'il nous faut
combattre donc oui moi je suis pour une
démocratie qui soit claire qui soit
ferme sur la base d'un programme
clairement écrit argumenté chiffré et
c'est vrai à ce point de mon propos je
veux vous dire quelque chose qui est un
peu à contrecourant de ce que j'entends
ici ou là je vous le dis je suis
extrêmement réservé sur l'usage du
référendum ce que nous venons de vivre
avec le brexit doit nous amener à
réfléchir la vérité c'est que pour les
peuples habitués à la démocratie comme
l' le peuple
français la vraie légitimité c'est le
moment où le peuple choisit son chef au
suffrage universel bien souvent
lorsqu'il est consulté par référendum
d'autres circonstances sont arrivées
avant d'autres se préparent et le vote
on le voit bien n'est pas toujours en
pleine cohérence avec ce que l'on peut
attendre ne vous m'éprenez pas je suis
pas en train d'expliquer qu'il y aurait
d'un côté les grands démocrates qui
aiment la démocratie référendaire et les
autres qui ne l'aiment pas je pense en
revanche que le référendum nous le
voyons depuis trop d'anné est est une
source à blocage et à inhibition et puis
naturellement il ouvre des boulevards à
tous les populistes alors alors moi je
pense que les référendum ça peut-être
des pièges qui se retournent contre ceux
qui les iniici il faut y faire attention
et je veux mettre ici en garde face à ce
risque ma deuxè remarque elle concerne
les
ordonnances les ordonnances pourquoi
faire n'est pas question qu'on les fasse
sans un contrat clair avec les Français
l'idée c'est que ces ordonnances elles
sont présentées avant dans leur totalité
il me semble qu'il faut 15 décisions
pour débloquer la France pas plus et
elle doit porter sur quatre sujets très
simples d'abord il faut libérer
l'économie de ces carcans cher Michel je
ne sais pas si ça s'appelle du
libéralisme ou pas je sais juste une
chose il y a trop d'impôts trop de taxes
et trop de code du travail je pense de
la même manière que la dictature
syndicale est devenue maintenant un
problème majeur pour notre
pays la dictature syndicale n'a plus
rien à voir plus rien à voir avec la
démocratie sociale et donc je pense
qu'il faudra lorsque certains voudront
parler de droit de grève leur dire
d'accord droit de manifester d'accord
mais certainement pas le droit de
bloquer ni encore moins le droit de
casser et donc il ne faudra pas craindre
quand tel ou tel viendra bloquer un
centre stratégique du pays une
raffinerie ou une centrale nucléaire lui
rappeler que quand on empêche l'autre de
travailler ça peut-être un licenciement
pour fautes lourd que de la même manière
il ne faudra pas craindre d'acter la fin
du paritarisme qui aujourd'hui depuis
1945 permet une cogestion
incompréhensible des caisses de sécurité
sociale de la même manière il nous
faudra ré réarmer la nation dans ce
domaine nous avons été pendant trop
longtemps bien naïfs face à toutes les
formes de menaces oui il faudra
augmenter les effectifs de police de
gendarmerie de magistrats de gardiens de
prison oui il faudra sans doute acter
alors ces milliers de Français qui
veulent s'engager pour le pays et faire
comme dans l'armée aujourd'hui par
contrat et donc la fin de l'emploi à vie
dans la fonction public pour les
nouveaux
entrants il faudra remobiliser eric
chotil a très bien dit la République
laïque face au communautarisme islamiste
oui il faudra que les imams parlent
français il faudra qu'ils aient un
certificat de laïcité par nos
universités il faudra interdire oui le
voile à l'université mais pas seulement
dans tous les établissements publics car
on voit bien derrière tout cela que
c'est un enfermement progressif de
beaucoup de nos jeunes filles et puis
relancer le patriotisme dès la jeunesse
pourquoi est-ce que on pleurniche tant
qu'on le fait sur nos jeunes qui ne
savent plus très bien à quelle nation
ils appartiennent et dans le même temps
on n'assume pas que dès l'école il ne
faudra pas craindre quelques mesures
symboliques fortes comme par exemple une
cérémonie durant lesqu tous les enfants
de France au même moment salueront le
drapeau tricolore chanteront l'hymne
national et pourront avoir une
perspective de faire un service civique
obligatoire au service du
pays enfin l'Europe et ce sera mon
dernier message je demande qu'en ce qui
concerne l'Europe on retienne bien ce
qui s'est passé avec le brexit le
divorce doit être acté très rapidement
même si nous l'avons regretté ça
peut-être mes chers amis je le dis comme
je le pense une chance pour la France
qui peut ainsi trouver de nouvelles
perspectives pour accueillir des
activités qui n'auront plus de sens en
Grande-Bretagne je pense qu'il ne faut
pas mentir aux gens un traité ça se fait
à 27 il faut attendre le plus petit
commun dénominateur pour accoucher de
textes qui sont souvent à l'au tiède on
l'a vu dans le passé et qui vont se
terminer par des réformes des
référendums où je crains le pire le
brexit c'est 30 ans qu'on sacré en
réalité à jouer avec le feu sur l'Europe
comme Bou émissaire en Angleterre il y a
réalité des sujets d'exaspération il
faut les traiter l'immigration
évidemment mais là encore il faut se
mettre d'accord à quelques-uns pour
verérrouiller nos frontières il n'y a
pas besoin d'un traité pour refaire
Schengen quant à la bureaucratie et bien
c'est très simple c'est aux Français de
retransposer les directives quand les
Allemands transposent une directive
angélique le sait c'est toujours dans
l'intérêt des Allemands quand les
Français transposent une directive c'est
toujours dans l'intérêt des
administrations je propose moi que l'on
détranspose toutes ces directives
excessives et on les retranspose à la
moyenne allemande et croyez-moi c'est le
pays qui changera vis-à-vis de l'Europe
voilà mes chers amis voilà mes chers
amis quelques pistes parmi d'autres les
défis qui nous attendent sont immenses
la vérité c'est qu'il nous faudra à la
fois porter secours à la France qui va
très mal et remotiver la France qui va
très bien et qu'on oublie trop souvent
jamais sans doute depuis 10 ans
l'attente l'attente d'une donne
politique radicalement nouvelle n'a été
aussi forte le message entendu partout
cette fois ne reculez pas cette fois ne
calez pas cette fois faites tout de
suite ce qui est bon pour le pays alors
oui c'est vrai celui qui l'emportera
j'en suis convaincu c'est celui qui
au-delà des discours des propos et du
talent celui dont on sera sûr que cette
fois il ne reculera plus merci
beaucoup merci
jeanfançois alors je vais donner la
parole à Christian Saint-Étienne sur le
projet économique en 3 minutes va nous
exposer les grands enjeux mais Serge
d'assau a une question je crois sur ce
sujet Serge vas-y tu fais comme toujours
à l'essentiel efficace synthétique Serge
d'assaau industriel tout à l'heure on a
dit qu'on pouvait dire ce qu'on veut
alors j'ai Galé carrément aujourd'hui
nous sommes en faillite et pourquoi nous
sommes en faillite parce que nous avons
un système fiscal deset et qui démotive
tout le monde et bien moi moi je vous
propose un nouveau système fiscal qui
vous permettra de résoudre tous vos
problèmes de revenir à l'équilibre
budgétaire et de retrouver la croissance
de la France parce que les gens payeront
moins d'impôts alors voilà ce que vous
propose aujourd'hui de flat taxe la flat
tax c'est quoi c'est un impôt c'est un
impôt à taux unique ce n'est pas un taux
progressif c'est-à-dire on défine un
impôt et tout le monde paye le même
impôt la même taxe quel que soit le
revenu on a déjà une c une une taxe la
CSG la CG est payé par l'ensemble des
Français à 8 % et bien la CG rapporte 84
milliards donc aujourd'hui l'impôt sur
le revenu n'est payé que 45 % des
contribuables et rapporte 70 milliards
alors je vous propose de choses de flat
taxes une flat taxe à 8 % jusqu'à 2200 €
et après 2200 € jusqu'à plus soif une
une flat taxe à 16 %. les Français ne
payeront plus que 16 % d'impôt
qume merci Serge pour te répondre un duo
de choc Christian Saint-Étienne et
mariechristine
D 2 minutes 30 chacun bonjour à tous
d'abord je je voulais affirmer que ce
programme économique et social pour la
partie économique et sociale qui a été
dirigé par éic sous la direction de
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est un projet de
réforme économique et sociale qui est à
la fois ambitieux cohérent et surtout
qui est conforme aux attentes de notre
pays nous ne sommes pas aux États-Unis
nous ne sommes pas au Royaume-Uni nous
sommes pas en Chine nous sommes en
France et c'est un programme pour la
France et qui correspond aux attentes
des
Français le point clé aussi c'est que
nous savons tous nous sommes écrasés par
la dépense publique 57 points de dépense
publique nous allons devoir faire un
effort de de baisse de cette dépenses
publiques mais le projet qui vous est
présenté vous propose une baisse ordonné
de ces dépenses
publiques progressive et juste voilà le
point fondamental c'est que les 100
milliards d'euros de baisse de dépenses
sont documentés et ils doivent permettre
de retrouver les grands équilibre
absolument nécessaire pour relancer une
économie de la production parce que
au-delà de la baisse de la dépense
l'impératif absolu c'est de reconstruire
en France une économie de la production
c'est ce que Serge d'assau invité à
faire il y a quelques instants par la
réforme de la flat taxe je reviendrai
tout à l'heure en une seconde sur cet
aspect là et c'est éléments seront
repris alors comment est-ce que nous
envisageons d'aller vers cette économie
de la production d'abord il faut
redonner aux employeurs l'envie
d'embaucher donc nous proposerons un
contrat de travail qui permette
facilement aux employeurs de suivre
l'évolution de l'activité tout en
permettant l'acquisition de droits et
une
formation progressive et adaptée aux
compétences des travailleurs qui leur
permettra donc de participer à cette
nouvelle économie de la
production pour faciliter ces embauches
il y a une proposition de zéro charge
sur les bas salaire qui va au-delà de la
situation actuelle ainsi que ce qui est
cohérent et va dans l'orientation
proposé par Serge d'asso une baisse des
impôts sur la production sur le
patrimoine et sur le
sur la production il s'agit à la fois de
baisser les impôts sur les sociétés et
les impôts sur les revenus de
l'investissement sur le patrimoine c'est
évidemment l'abolition de l'ISF et sur
le revenu c'est une baisse
des seuil d'imposition donc ce que nous
voulons c'est affirmer trois grands
principes pour l'impôt la stabilité des
système d'imposition la prévisibilité de
l'impôt par des lois de finances
pluriannuel
et bien sûr la neutralité de l'impôt par
rapport aux décisions qui sont prises
par les individus parce que les Français
sont parfaitement responsables ils
savent ce qui est dans leur intérêt et
nous ne devons pas avoir une fiscalité
qui les oriente vers des placements qui
ne sont pas souhaitables pour le pays
nous voulons que l'épargne des Français
serve à la reconstruction de l'appareil
productif le l'enjeu fondamental c'est
donc la production le développement de
l'économie l'investissement la recherche
pour créer les 2 à 3 millions d'emplois
dont nous avons besoin pour que tous les
Français retrouvent la dignité à
laquelle ils ont droit merci Christian
Marie-Christine dalos député du Jura
pour compléter sur les questions
budgétaires et fiscales bonjour très
brièvement et en complément de ce que
vient de dire Christian c'est vrai que
nous avons travaillé ensemble sous la la
direction de notre chef d'orchestre Eric
vert moi je voudrais à dire Christian a
dit c'est un projet le projet fiscal et
économique porté par les républicains il
est c'est un projet
ambitieux pragmatique mais moi je vais
dire il est surtout réaliste moi je suis
intimement convaincu que c'est les
mesures dont la France a besoin la
réalité elle est là alors Christian vous
a parlé des grands axes l'impôt société
l'impôt sur le revenue des ménages les
prélèvements sociaux il y a une réalité
qu'on oublie aujourd'hui et François
Hollande nous a laissé penser que
l'obligation de revenir à un équilibre
des finances publiques c'està-dire de
réduire notre déficit c'était une une
obligation imposée par l'Europe pas vrai
enfin l'Europe on a traité on a signé un
traité de stabilité le TSCG le traité de
stabilité de gouvernance euh des des
finances publiques va faire que
normalement nous devriions nous aurions
dû être en 2017 à zéro bon nous n'y
serons pas bien évidemment nous avons é
2015 avec 3,5 % du PIB de déficit public
il y a une légère amélioration mais qui
est complètement exogène qui n'est pas
du fait de la bonne gestion de la de la
gouvernance socialiste qui est surtout
du fait de la baisse du prix du pétrole
de la baisse des taux d'intérêt c'est
une réalité qui a profité à ce
gouvernement honteusement il en a il
s'en est attribué les bénéfice la
réalité c'est que notre situation
financière économique nationale elle est
catastrophique donc
mais la réalité aussi c'est que ce n'est
absolument pas pour faire plaisir à la
Commission européenne que nous devons
revenir à un niveau de déficit qui soit
à l'équilibre enfin qui ne soit plus un
déficit qui soit un équilibre budgétaire
c'est le premier principe budgétaire
d'un ménage d'une entreprise et
normalement et d'une collectivité
territoriale la réalité c'est que nous
devrions pouvoir financer nos dépenses
avec nos recette c'est pas du tout le
cas aujourd'hui nous finançons une
grosse partie de nos dépenses avec de la
dette la rité c'est celle-ci donc pour
faire très simple aujourd'hui nous avons
prévu un projet ambitieux qui va nous
ramener théoriquement dans les 3 ans à
une maîtrise de notre déficit
fondamental et au-delà de ça elle est
fondamentale pourquoi cette maîtrise de
notre déficit parce qu'elle va nous
permettre d'avoir une maîtrise de notre
avenir parce que si demain nous devions
continuer à dériver tel que le
gouvernement socialiste l'a fait et bien
nous serons sous tutelle sous tutelle de
l'Europe sous tutelle des commissaires
européens et l'objectif c'est que nous
revenions à notre souveraineté nationale
je sais que vous comme moi nous sommes
attachés à la souveraineté de la France
c'est cela le projet des républicains au
niveau financier si merci
Marie-Christine contrechoc fiscal on
baisse les dépenses et les recettes en
même temps la parole est maintenant à
Christian Jacob président du groupe des
Républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale
bien mes chers amis écoutez ça fait
d'abord plaisir de se retrouver je suis
pas le premier à le dire à cette tribune
et je suis pas le premier non plus à le
penser c'est conseil nationaux c'est
d'abord un moment d'échange mais c'est
aussi l'occasion tout simplement de se
de se retrouver j'ai fait le compte tout
à l'heure en voiture 290 jours nous nous
sépare de du premier tour de l'élection
présid pridenti nous sommes quelquesuns
à compter compter les jours depuis
l'arrivée de François Hollande à
l'Élysée mais chaque jour oui vous aussi
vous les compter non mais on est
plusieurs alors chaque jour davantage de
français nous nous rejoignent et
considère que ce temps qui nous sépare
de l'alternance est de plus en plus
insupportable depuis 2012 nous sommes à
l'Assemblée nationale au combat pour
porter nos propositions pour s'opposer
au gouvernement ce combat il est mené
dans tous les domaine ils ont
pratiquement tous été évoqués ce matin
que ce soit dans le domaine économique
social dans celui de la la sécurité de
l'enseignement de la recherche de
l'agriculture de la politique familiale
et cela ce travail qui a été fait
aujourd'hui pour préparer notre notre
projet il s'appuie bien souvent sur le
travail de nos parlementaires alors je
voudrais les saluer tous mes collègues
qui sont ici bien sûr nos députés
nationaux les députés européens les
sénateurs vous savez vous pouvez les
applaudir d'abord ça leur fait plaisir
et ensuite c'est
justifié et on a besoin de ça c'est un
travail qui est parfois et même souvent
disons-le ingrat dans ces périodes
d'opposition parce que on a le sentiment
en quelque sorte de ramer contre contre
la falaise mais pour cela pour faire ce
travail au Parlement nous avons besoin
d'avoir des parlementaires de terrain
qui soit en prise avec les réalités vous
voyez où je veux en venir ça veut dire
que nous avons besoin d'avoir des
parlementaires qui puissent cumuler un
mandat de parlementairire et un mandat
d'exécutif
local si on n'accepte pas ça si on reste
dans la ligne de ce qui a été voté par
le gouver par la majorité de gauche
d'ailleurs un certain nombre aujourd'hui
commence à s'apercevoir de leurs erreurs
mais nous changeons complètement nos
institutions et je le dis devant le
président du Sénat le Sénat n'y
résistera pas comment les sénateurs
auront une légitimité sil ne peuvent
plus représenter les collectivités
territoriales s'ils ne peuvent plus
présider une collectivité
territoriale et pour les députés on ira
tout droit vers la proportionnelle
intégrale et on retrouvera les Herms de
la 4e République et ce sera une chambre
ingouvernable c'est ça qu'il y a
derrière l'enjeu du cumul des mandats
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
reste avec un certain nombre de
collègues très attaché à la possibilité
de cumuler mandat local en crache sur le
terrain et mandat
national alors sur ce sujet on entend
tous les mêmes les mêmes arguments mais
tu as vu l'opinion publique évolue les
médias la
presse les sondages et cetera vous savez
souvenez-vous de cette phrase de Jacques
Chirac qui disait à force d'aller dans
le sens du vent on finit parfois par
voir le destin d'une feuille morte
elle était jolie cette phrase
alors dans la période où où on
est vous saz on est au moment de des
résultats scolaires des fins de l'année
scolaire et si finalement on ramenait
notre quinena le quinquena de de
François Hollande à une année scolaire
on serait quelque chose comme en avril à
peu près au moment de de l'orientation
scolaire et je crois qu'à ce moment-là
et bien on ne demanderait pas le
redoublement on demanderait l'exclusion
immédiate de l'établissement de l'élève
Hollande
et les Français ne s'y trompent pas 88 %
d'entre eux ont une mauvaise opinion du
président de la République le péché
originel vous savez où il est il est
d'abord dans le mensonge de cette de la
campagne présidentielle qu'il a mené
mais il est aussi sur un autre sujet je
vaux attirer votre attention au moment
de la la primaire il est aussi le
lendemain du premier tour de la primaire
de gauche où à ce moment-là François
Hollande pour battre Martin au a dû
faire l'alliance entre Mbour Emmanuel
Vals ça été le mariage de la carpe et du
lapin et on voit bien où ça les a mené
il faut savoir en tirer quelques
enseignement c'est pour cela qu'il est
important aujourd'hui que nous ayons un
projet que notre famille politique se
rassemble sur l'essentiel après viendra
le temps de la concurrence mais d'abord
soyons fort sur nos idées parce que si
on n pas au clair sur ce sujetl on a
effectivement on peut en courir les
mêmes risques que les
socialistes moi je veux vous dire dire
aussi que je suis fier du projet qui a
été travaillé d'abord parce que je l'ai
dit il s'est souvent appuyé sur les
travaux de nos assemblées mais ce qu'a
fait Éric convention après convention
avec la participation de tous les
militants qui ont souhaité s'y impliquer
avec les cadres de notre mouvement avec
l'ensemble des élus depuis 18 mois
l'équipe dirigeante de notre famille
politique a consacré toute son énergie à
préparer ce projet à préparer ce qui va
être en quelque sorte le fondement de la
reconquête et de de la victoire pour
2017 plutôt que de se préoccuper à se
creuser la tête pour trouver la dernière
idée à la mode qui nous divise le choix
a été fait dans notre famille politique
sous l'autorité de Nicolas Sarkozi de se
rassembler et ça nous devons vraiment en
féliciter toute notre équipe dirigeante
bravo à eux
oui il y en a aussi de ce côté-là c'est
vrai et puis moi je suis dans cette
période vous savez je suis euh élu dans
une circonscription rurale j'ai 151
communes et je fais une réunion publique
dans chacune de mes communes donc j'y
suis en ce moment je étais j'y étais
hier soir et on voit bien que au-delà
des sujets économiques sociaux et tous
les points qui ont pu être évoqués ce
qui manque et ce que les les gens
ressentent le plus difficilement c'est
le manque d'autorité de l'État cette
manque de reconnaissance de l'autorité
de la parole donnée et et l'autorité
vous savez ça n'est pas les énervements
successifs de Manuel Val sous ses coups
de menton à répétition l'autorité ça
s'impose naturellement ça s'impose avec
sérénité regardez ce qui s'est passé
depuis 8 jours sur ces manifestations de
la CGT on est passé et c'est un ancien
syndicaliste qui vous le dit on est
passé de l'interdiction totale de
manifester à la manifestation statique
ensuite on appelle on a imaginé la
manifestation circulaire c'est qu'on a
définir un bloc de maison et on allait
les faire tourner est autour et tout
cela pour terminer avec Emmanuel Vals
qui comme d'habitude après avoir fait
beaucoup de moulinet avec ses bras après
avoir donné beaucoup coup de menton et
bien s'est couché devant la CGT et sur
ce sujet voyez manuel Vals il a pas été
ridicule il a été pitoyable dans
l'attitude qui a été la
sienne la réalité c'est que les Français
ne supportent plus ce gouvernement et ce
président ce président qui est le
président du chômage de masse pour les
jeunes qui est le président du déficit
public avec les cadeaux électoraux 10
milliards d'euros depuis quelques jours
je le dis devant nos collègues de la la
commission des finances mais qui ont
Christine Marie-Christine l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est aussi le président
de la dette qui froule les 100 % de
richesse nationale c'est aussi le
président des impôts qui ont frappé les
classes moyennes c'est le président de
l'assistana c'est le président du RSA
jeune de la CMU de laame du tir payant
c'est le président anti famille qui a
rompu ce lien entre les familles de
France et la nation c'est aussi le
président qui a dégradé l'éducation
nationale avec la réforme des rythmes
scolaires et celle du programme des
collèges c'est aussi le président qui
avec Madame tobira incarneré le laxisme
judiciaire et le président de la
République c'est aussi ce président
peut-être pour le plus grave qui n'a pas
eu le courage de prendre les mesures
exceptionnelles qu'imposait la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical éic cioti
Guillaume l'arrivé l'ont évoqué tout à
l'heure mais ça c'est vraiment le
reproche que l'on peut lui faire nous
avions dans ce domaine des propositions
depuis le premier jour nous avons encore
été les présentés la semaine dernière à
chaque fois on nous dit qu'on sera
entendu mais jusque maintenant on ne l'a
pas été du moins au niveau on le
souhaitait alors j'ai remarqué le CLIN
d'œil euh je veux tout simplement vous
dire et je vais en arrêté là vous voyez
que les chantiers sont sont énormes sur
tous les sujets et c'est pour ça qu'il
ne fallait pas et c'est un paysan qui
vous le dit il fallait pas mettre la
charue avant les bœfs il fallait bien
commencer dans l'ordre et l'ordre c'est
d'abord d'avoir un projet qui nous
rassemble qui nous unit et après va
venir le temps de savoir qui l'incarne
qui le porte mais aujourd'hui à partir
du travail qui a été réalisé et bien
nous avons le matériel nous militants
pour aller à la rencontre des Français
et leur dire voilà ce que les
républicains ont à vous proposer et
voilà derrière quelle barnière on veut
vous rassembler merci merci question
je vous remercie Christan Jacobe parce
que vous savez c'est pas facile d'être
président de groupe pendant la mandature
il a traverser des moments pas faciles
et il a toujours été notre point fixe
au-delà de nos sensibilités au-delà de
nos amitiés chapeau Christian
merci les amis si ceux qui donnent des
conférences de presse forcément
passionnantes pouvaient les donner à
l'extérieur ça permettrait aux 1000
personnes qui sont dans la salle
d'écouter les orateurs
je veux saluer françois Barouin le
président de l'association des maires
qui nous a
rejoint et avant de laisser Gérard
Larcher président du Sénat conclure
notre matinée je voudrais demander à
Maud fonenois notre délégué à
l'environnement de nous dire quelques
mots sur l'environnement sur l'écologie
à visage
humain merci merci Luc bonjour bonjour à
tous je sais que le temps est compté on
me l'a rappelé 10 fois comme je suis une
sportive je sais respecter les règles si
euh j'ai décidé de m'engager auprès de
vous auprès de chacun d'entre vous et
auprès de toi Nicolas c'est parce que
j'avais envie de porter une autre vision
de l'écologie et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
les républicains c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire nous avons dans
ce programme qui vous a été distribué
une vraie vision pour une écologie
pragmatique une écologie modérée une
écologie réaliste et une écologie
applicable je sais pas vous mais moi
j'en avais un peu à pass des discours
tout à la fois alarmistes culpabilisant
dogmatiqu
stigmatisant avec un discours toujours
contre tout mais jamais pour rien
aujourd'hui la vraie écologie c'est une
écologie des faits du concret du réel
qui prend compte qui prend en compte les
besoins de notre société et c'est bien
différent d'une religion de
l'écologie
aujourd'hui nous pouvons incarner cela
au sein des républicains et ça se
décline dans tous les domaines vous
allez le voir on a travaillé autant sur
les domaines de de l'énergie que la
préservation de la biodiversité que de
la préservation du milieu marin
aujourd'hui que ça soit en terme
d'énergie oui nous allons développer les
énergies renouvelables oui aujourd'hui
il faut investir dans la recherche dans
l'innovation dans le Progrès évidemment
que le discours du sitnel c'était mieux
avant n'a pu lieu d'être aujourd'hui le
cétait mieux avant quand est-ce que le
c'était mieux avant c'était en 1750
quand l'espérance de vie était de 27 ans
en moyenne aujourd'hui non nous voulons
cette innovation nous voulons cette
croissance que veut dire la décroissance
dans les favel et dans les bidenvillees
donc aujourd'hui l'énergie oui l'énergie
de Devin c'est l'énergie renouvelable
mais elle se fera pas en réouvrant des
mines à ciel ouvert de charbon comme
font nos amis allemands c'est
aujourd'hui pas
possible aujourd'hui oui l'écologie ça
passera aussi par les agriculteurs par
les pêcheurs par les chasseurs
aujourd'hui ces secteursl ont travaillé
avec nous ils sont pas contre ils sont
co constructeurs de cette biodiversité
et c'est bien ça qu'il faut comprendre
et dans le domien maritime c'est
exactement la même chose aujourd'hui on
est la deuxième puissance maritime
mondiale il serait temps de s'en
souvenir et d'avoir une vraie politique
maritime c'est ce qu'on vous propose
dans ce programme j'ai été élu en région
Provence al Côte d'Azur au côté de
Christian Estrosi là-bas nous mettons
déjà aujourd'hui en place une politique
environnementale concrète basée non pas
sur les professions FO mais sur les
actes pour que la région provenceazur
soit une région exemplaire sur cette
thématique là et c'est ce que nous
ferons pour la France en 2017 là où il y
a une volonté il y a un chemin et
Nicolas tu as cette volonté merci
[Applaudissements]
merci
Nicolas je voudrais vraiment une
nouvelle fois remercier fis parce que le
courage n'est pas la qualité la mieux
répandue
et bien voilà une jeune femme qui s'est
engagée sans rien
demander au service de la France et des
idées de notre famille politique
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on ait beaucoup
de mot de fonoir qui nous
rejoignent la deuxème
chose je voudrais le dire à Serge
d'assau parce que il y a un conseil
national mais on n pas contre
nous et moi j'aime la jeunesse de Serge
j'aime j'aime ces qualités
entrepreneuriales mais je lui dis je
suis président d'un mouvement politique
qui veut parler à tous les Français sans
aucune exception je ne suis pas le
président d'une famille politique qui
parle à une catégorie de
Français tous les Français les plus
modestes comme les plus puissants et le
projet fiscal que nous avons il doit
parler à tout le monde naturellement
qu'il faut baisser les charges sur les
entreprises pour qu'on reste une de
production naturellement qu'il faut
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu sur les
familles qui ont été matraquées mais il
faut aussi penser aux ouvriers dans les
usines au salariés les plus modestes qui
ne payent pas d'impôt et qui doivent se
dire que dans le projet des républicains
il y a aussi une place pour eux je ne
veut pas qu'on puisse nous caricaturer
alors si la flat taxe ça consiste à ce
que ceux qui payaient pas d'impôt
faaient 8 % d'impôt et que ceux qui ont
payé beaucoup on paye 16 je crains qu'on
ait des difficultés à parler à 65
millions de Français et nous ce qu'on
veut c'est parler à 65 millions de
Français et qu'on ne me fasse pas passer
pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas pour la
baisse des impôts je suis pour qu'on
parle à tous les Français sans aucune
exception enfin dernier point j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le le le discours de
Jean-François et et et et je me suis
reconnu dans beaucoup de choses qu' a
dit mais j'ai
voulu que dans le mouvement qui est le
nôtre on ait un débat mais si on est la
formation politique qui est contre le
référendum on aura du mal à dire qu'on
est la formation politique qui est pour
le peuple et si on est pour la formation
politique qui minutite pour les
ordonnances on aura du mal à dire au
parlementaires qu'on est pour le débat
parce que s'il y a pas de débat
référendur et s'il y a pas de débat au
Parlement on risque d'être une formation
politique qui n'aime pas le débat or je
pense que quand on est courageux on aime
le débat et c'est la raison pour
laquelle Jean-François moi qui n'ai
jamais reculé pendant 5 ans ne nous
trompons pas sur les quinquen jamais et
bien je n'ai jamais voulu le 493 jamais
même si à l'époque nombreux dans ma
majorité le demandaient parce que 493 de
François Hollande c'est une preuve de
faiblesse parce que quand tu n'acceptes
pas le débat pas toi François Hollande
quand onaccepte pas le débat au
Parlement on l'a dans la rue voilà la
réalité des choses j'ai beaucoup admiré
madame tcher monsieur ran mais c'était
une époque où les médias n'étaient pas
ce qu'ils sont maintenant c'était une
époque où on av'ait pas des chaînes
d'info qui créent eux-même l'événement
qui sont au début pendant après la
manifestation et nous les républicains
nous aimons le débat nous n'avons pas
peur du débat
contre idéet contre projet qu'on va
gagner pas vous privant du
débat ce débat là c'est un débat
intéressant il fait
commencer